Now, let me get into the cursing part.
Now, why did I do
that
poll
which I thought I heard J. Warner had
some fun at?
Because I was hearing also Christians
that I love and I respect saying that
they preferred if I didn't swear as
much. All right, one
such person is Pro-Life if she's here.
Pro-Life Chloe, you here?
You here, Pro-Life Chloe?
Say what?
Uh-oh. And they remind me of James White
cuz I know Thaddeus is going to
manifest. It's okay, Thaddeus.
You can do some more sessions, all
right?
Keep the faming me. I just want the
receipts. See how God will guide me in
the future. Sal, my boy, come on here so
I don't sue you, too.
Okay, this is what Pro-Life Chloe
shared. Let me see.
Let's see here. Say what?
What do you think if you go out on a
tube? This is what she said.
You there, Pro-Life?
Here's what she said here.
First, I do not agree with the language
used by Sam.
As followers of Christ, we are called to
let no corrupt word proceed out of your
mouth, but what is good of necessity for
necessary edification.
Speech should reflect holiness, not
anger or pride. Okay, so
So, now this will be my
finale, meaning
I'm going to explain to you
and I've never said that I'm perfect and
sinless and flawless when I curse people
out. That would be a lie.
But now, I'm going to try.
Buddy, that was my story, brother. But
what I'm trying to do is not talk about
my ex-wife anymore.
I don't want to talk about her anymore.
It's past. We're going to move on.
Please pray the following for me. Can
you pray, your warriors? Here's my
prayer request. Are you ready?
If you love me for the sake of Lord and
you feel Christ will use me in ministry
till I die, here's my prayer request.
Are you ready?
Here's my prayer requests.
Let me know.
Number one, pray God will give me
miraculous strength, power
self-control
tighten his bit my mouth as leash on my
neck to never mention my ex-wife again.
She's
very crushed, heartbroken, not happy.
I don't want to add to her misery
because of the situation.
She thinks that I'm out to hurt her.
That's not my agenda. I don't want to
hurt her.
Hurt people hurt people. I'm hurt
because I don't have my daughters.
Pray I can now forget about what
happened.
Move forward, not mention her again and
what she's done.
Pray I don't have the strength to do it.
I don't have the strength to do it. I'm
letting you know.
Forgive me if at times I fail. I don't
want to, but I know I'm a wicked sinner.
I want to now let go and let God bring
healing.
If she's going to repent, she'll repent.
I just got to focus on my healing.
And I got to focus on my daughters.
They're hurt.
They're devastated and only God knows
the scars they'll carry into adulthood.
Pray God will constrain me.
I'm letting you know I don't have the
strength to do it. I'm going to trust in
my Lord Jesus.
Right? Secondly, pray God now will reign
in
my mouth.
Pray God will give me power not to just
flippantly cuss people out. To reach the
point where I can just ignore them
totally.
Right?
Pray for that.
Right? Even though I've told people this
is 18 and older, pray for that. Pray for
that. I'll let you know again. I get
triggered very easily.
In fact, there was a comment here that
almost triggered me.
And I was about to say something. I
don't have strength I'm letting you guys
know I don't have strength.
I don't have strength.
I cry out to Jesus
to be my strength and my power because I
want him to shine and not me to be a
stumbling block. So, pray for that.
By the power of the Holy Spirit. If I
can then reach a level where I can
constrain myself, then we will make it
right where even children can listen
because my you'll see it's 18 and older.
I don't have strength.
I'm being honest. So, if I slip, don't
condemn me, please.
Pray God will also give me miraculous
strength and discipline to die to these
vices such as food addiction gluttony,
laziness, slothness strict discipline to
get healthier
holier, practice what I preach, and pray
God rein me in from lust, destroy
lustful desires, shield this woman, keep
her pure and safe
until unless we get married.
Pray for that. So
with that said, I want to remind you
again
because again, people don't watch
sessions.
People will say that I call people's
mothers
That I want to address.
Number one, when I say your mother's a
I've said I'm not trying to I'm
just letting you know so we can move on
cuz I want to address that allegation.
I'm talking
about people being
children of Satan
children of the of Babylon.
The of Babylon.
So, when I say you're a and your
mother's a I mean you are a
spiritual a son of the of
Babylon. Not saying I'm going to do it
again. I'm just trying to put
things in perspective.
When I say your mother's a Shia
Shia prostitute, it's to show you how
filthy and wicked and evil Muhammad is
to prostitute women. So, I'm saying if
you're not a Muslim
your mother's a Shia meaning your
mother is the of Babylon
and does mut'ah.
I know people don't get it, but that's
okay.
But I'm just trying to explain.
Even though there's been videos
explaining this.
Not because I want to do it again. I'm
going to try now to go a higher level.
When I call you a bastard
because I'm saying you're a spiritual
bastard. So, let me just one more time
as a way to finish and move on
just to explain myself so I don't get
oh, Sam called me No, I didn't, man.
Do you understand? I didn't. Do you
understand I'm using
these to refer that you are a dog of
Satan, spiritual spiritual
bastard, and your mother's a of
Babylon and that mut'ah is disgusting
because Muhammad was disgusting.
So, you mean when they talk about me and
you weren't disgusted by that?
And you weren't praying for them to
repent, brother? Okay, brother. We
appreciate you.
So, anyway, here, let me show you some
receipts.
We were saying the
word.
Caught in the trap and I can't walk out.
Just give you some more stuff.
And then we're going to move on. That's
it. I'm done. I've done my piece.
And Lord willing, I'll try to do some
streams over the weekend till Tuesday,
but I need to get back. I'm tired. I
want to get back to the site.
All right. Hey, let me let me let's go
to Hebrews 12:8.
And if you are apart from chastening,
you have them in chastening of which all
have become partakers, then bastards are
you. And not sons. See? You bastard,
see?
What about and your mother's a
All right.
[Music]
With whom the kings of the earth did
commit whoredom.
And made drunk from the wine of her
whoredom.
Were those inhabiting the earth. Who?
The great Babylon.
Her hand full of abominations and
uncleanness of her whoredom. And upon
her forehead was a name written, "Secret
Babylon the Great, the mother of
whores."
Okay, can you at least represent me
correctly?
No, don't don't believe that
Original, don't believe that.
That's Revelation 17.
You got it?
You got it. That's true. You're right.
This guy's right. You're right. Hey, can
I call people Muhammad instead? Will
that be good enough?
Okay, do you guys now can you represent
me at least accurately?
You may not like it. That's fine.
Okay, can someone clip this even Christ
overall Jeremy has clipped this
thousands of times.
All right.
Everyone got it? Rumble, you got it now?
Okay.